bienvenidos al vídeo de cómo encontrar
suma de enteros y seguramente te estás
preguntando por qué estoy poniendo este
vídeo en la sección de promedios pero
bueno puedes hacer un poco de memoria y
recordar que un promedio al final es la
suma de varios datos dividido entre la
cantidad de datos que hay y bueno decidí
trabajar con este vídeo ahorita porque
en este vídeo voy a hablar acerca de
suma de enteros que al final otra
variante de estos problemas sería
tomarnos el promedio de enteros pero
bueno empecemos con un problema y este
problema dice así la suma de cinco
enteros consecutivos la suma de cinco
enteros consecutivos es igual a 200 cual
es el menor cuál
es el menor de estos enteros
cuál es el menor de estos enteros de
estos cinco enteros y bueno lo primero
que voy a hacer es llamarle a x el
entero más pequeño de estos 52
consecutivos entonces vamos a ponerlo
aquí x es el entero más pequeño de estos
cinco enteros consecutivos el entero más
pequeño de estos enteros y bueno si
tenemos cinco enteros consecutivos
podremos tener por ejemplo 1 2 3 4 y 5 o
podría ser por ejemplo 10 11 12 13 14 no
lo sé pero lo que sí sé es que son
consecutivos y son enteros es decir no
estamos contando aquí fracciones ni nada
con punto decimal y si el entero más
pequeños x entonces el entero que les
seguiría sería x + 1 el que seguiría
sería x + 2
el que sigue sería x + 3 y el que sigue
x +
date cuenta que aquí tenemos 50 euros y
son consecutivos si x por ejemplo vale 5
entonces el que le sigue es 6 el que le
sigue 7 el que le sigue es 8 y el que
sigue es 9 recuerda no espantarse con
las equis lo más importante que veas es
que son consecutivos porque le voy
sumando 1 al siguiente entero perfecto y
yo lo que quiero tomarme es la suma de
estos cinco enteros entonces cuánto vale
la suma de todos estos que tengo yo aquí
bueno si contamos las equis tengo 1 2 3
4 5 x es decir x + xxx lo cual es 5 x
tengo 5x y además tengo una parte de
números libres que es uno más 2 que es 3
más 13 664 es 10 entonces la suma de
todos estos enteros que tengo aquí esto
es la suma de x + x + 1 + x + 2 + x + 34
y yo sé que esto es igual a 200 porque
es lo que me dice el problema y de aquí
ya tengo una ecuación en donde puedo
despejar la x porque si yo paso este 10
del otro lado restando
va a quedar que 5x es igual a ciento
noventa y ahora dividiendo todo entre
cinco me va a quedar que x es igual a am
y cuento de 190 entre 5 haber 5 cabe
tres veces en diecinueve y esto es 15 3
por 5 15 y sobran 4 bajo el cero y
después 5 por 848 por 140 y esto es
exacto el entero más pequeños 38 es
decir x ya encontré el valor de x queda
el entero más pequeño y bueno esto
parece estar bastante sencillo no es así
ahora qué te parece si yo te pregunto
cuál es el promedio de estos cinco
enteros consecutivos y bueno los voy a
poner aquí es 38 39 40 41 y 42 y yo lo
que quiero saber es cuál es el promedio
de la suma de estos ocho enteros
consecutivos y bueno realmente no
tenemos que tomar los 38 39 40 41 42
porque ya sabemos que la suma de estos
vale 200 por tanto en promedio 200 en 35
lo cual es
146 40 40 el promedio es 40 y bueno
podremos fijarnos en cuál es el número
que está en medio de estos y ese va a
ser un promedio porque estamos hablando
de enteros consecutivos o inclusive
podría modificar un poquito este
problema y pensar por ejemplo en la
siguiente expresión podría decir a ver
si la suma de 52 consecutivos es 200
cuál es su promedio y tú me vas a decir
bueno es que realmente no necesitaríamos
sacar los 50 y los consecutivos porque
el promedio es 200 entre 5 lo cual es 40
bueno ya hasta que este problema así que
creo que fue muy sencillo vamos a poner
uno un poco más difícil y dice la suma
de 7 de 7 impar es la suma de 7 impares
y vamos a ponerle números impares la
suma de siete números impares
es 217 y todo esto lo estoy tratando de
hacer en mi cabeza así que espero que
salga la suma de 7 números impares 217 y
la pregunta es cuál es el mayor de estos
números cuál es el mayor de estos
números no no no espera números no es
enteros enteros impares bueno de hecho
si estoy hablando de impares tengo que
hablar de enteros entonces creo que esto
es redundante a siete enteros impares y
bueno pues más grande estos números no
números no perdón pues el más grande de
estos enteros perdón perdón es que como
puedes darte cuenta estoy haciendo todo
esto en el camino ando muy
desconcentrado de hecho justo hoy en la
mañana mi esposa me diagnóstico que
tengo un vértigo benigno lo que pasó es
que hoy en la mañana me marea mucho y
creo que sigo un poco aturdido así que
también perdonadme por eso pero
en fin vamos a tratar de resolver el
problema y dice a x voy a decir que es
el más grande de estos enteros impares y
bueno cuál es el número que está abajo
de x pues no es x menos 1 porque x menos
uno sería impar sería x menos 2 y de
hecho espera espera espera
tengo la suma de siete enteros impares
consecutivos aquí lo voy a poner esto es
muy importante consecutivos perdóname
perdóname perdóname estoy ha sido mi
mayor esfuerzo para confundirte lo más
posible pero bueno necesitan ser enteros
impares consecutivos y darte cuenta que
lo que voy a hacer es saltarme los pares
por ejemplo puedo tener 13 5 o 7 y así
sucesivamente hay que saltarse los
impares y por eso le voy a quitar a
sumar 2 para obtener puros números
impares
pero como x es el más grande entonces
voy a quitar dos después x menos 4 quito
4 después x menos 6 x menos 8 x 10 x
y creo que ya que está en los 7 ya tengo
aquí 7 enteros impares estoy suponiendo
que son impares y consecutivos donde x
es el más grande de todos estos y bueno
me dicen que la suma de todos estos es
217 así que vamos a sumar los 7 x y aquí
tengo 24 son 6 6 y 2 son 12 12 y 8 son
20 y aquí son 32 entonces 7 x menos 32
esto es igual a 217 y ahora si sumó 32
de ambos lados de la ecuación voy a
obtener que 7x es igual y sumando del
otro lado me queda 249 y ahora sí cuánto
es 249 entre 7 y aquí algo me vuelve mal
si se me viene a ver 32 más 17
49 si esto está bien a ver vamos a
explicar la suma quin 26 después 6 y 6
son 12 y 8 son 2020 más 10 son 30 y 30
más 12 son 42 ya ves mis sentidos
arácnidos de matemático me decía que
algo está mal por aquí entonces ya que
tengo el 42 corregido y soy muy valiente
porque todo esto me guste tomando en
tiempo real si yo paso 42 entonces aquí
me queda 259 y ahora si algo me olía que
estaba mal aquí es 259 y fíjate que la
división va a estar súper chévere 3 por
7 21 y 25 menos 21 puntos 4 bajó un 9 y
aquí hay un 7 y entonces x es igual a 37
hemos terminado y bueno como cometí
muchos errores en este problema y esto
es por hacerlo en tiempo real déjame
repasar este problema y el problema de
sea si la suma de siete enteros impares
consecutivos es 217
cuál es el más grande de estos enteros
impares ya había dicho que x es el
entero impar más grande que por cierto
quedamos que es 37 y después sigue 35 33
31 29 27 y 25 y lo único que hice es
tomarme todos los impares por eso iba
quitando de dos en dos y después sume
todas las x todas las constantes libres
y llegué a esta ecuación donde resuelve
para x